the interior of our bodies is hidden to
us
what happens beneath the skin is
mysterious fearful
amazing in antiquity the body's internal
structure was the subject of speculation
fantasy and some study but there were
few efforts to represent it in pictures
the invention of the printing press in
the 15th century
and the cascade of print technologies
that followed
helped to inspire a new spectacular
science of anatomy
and new spectacular visions of the body
anatomical imagery proliferated detailed
and informative
but also whimsical surreal beautiful
and grotesque a dream anatomy that
reveals as much about the outer world
as it does the inner self
over the centuries anatomy has become a
visual vocabulary of realism
we regard the anatomical body as our
inner reality
a medium through which we imagine
society culture and the human condition
drawn principally from the collections
of the national library of medicine
dream anatomy shows off the anatomical
imagination
in some of its most astonishing
incarnations
from 1500 to the present
[Music]
with the founding of the first medical
schools in medieval europe
anatomy ascended to a prominent position
in the medical curriculum
human dissection was performed as a
ritual that illustrated the treatises of
revered ancient authors
and that dramatized the power and
knowledge of the medical profession
the cutting open of the body was not a
scientific study of the cadaver
but a performance designed to illustrate
the anatomical treatises of galen
the great anatomist of antiquity galen
was an
iconic figure for people in
the middle ages he represented
the sum of learned authority
on the human body but the old anatomies
were primarily based on the dissection
of animals
and filled with numerous errors
the mid 15th century invention of the
printing press
and the rise of a new spirit of critical
inquiry
associated with the renaissance inspired
a scientific revolution in anatomy
anatomists began to dissect in order to
investigate the structure of the body
and produced texts illustrated with
images based on their dissections
published in 1543 the humane corporis
fabrica by andreas verzailius
was the founding text of modern anatomy
the fabrica set a new standard for
accuracy
and a new standard for the artistry of
scientific illustration
it's part of a larger intellectual
movement in
society in which people are rethinking
ancient wisdom
and creating new wisdom and it's not
enough though
to make a direct empirical observation
of the body and criticize the ancient
text
visalias also says we have to make new
texts and these new texts viserious
argues cannot just be written
descriptions of the human body
they need to be illustrated texts and
they have to show
something of what the anatomist sees and
that is the visalian revolution in
anatomy and it created
the modern science of anatomy
in the early modern era 1450 to 1750
the boundary between art and science was
ill-defined
anatomists and their artist
collaborators made use of familiar modes
of representation
the iconography of landscape nudity
mythology and christianity
artists tried to create illustrations
that were accurate
but also amazing beautiful and
entertaining
in the early modern period science meant
any organized body of knowledge
so you could have the science of
theology or the science of law
art meant any work from the human hand
that involved
skill people often talked about the art
of dissection or the art of medicine
the presumption is that a successful
scientific illustration would also have
to be an artful
illustration
between 1680 and 1800 anatomists began
purging
imaginative elements from scientific
illustration
the truth value of anatomy they argued
was compromised by visual metaphors
fantastic landscapes and comic poses
ultimately two styles of anatomical
realism
emerged one aimed to show the reality of
dissection
the cutting open of a particular body
with all the prosthetics
furniture and setting of dissection and
the ugliness of anatomical mutilation
the other aimed to show a higher reality
displaying beautified
cleaned up idealized bodies and body
parts
that float in air with no reference to
any one dissection
as old print technologies were perfected
and new ones invented
anatomical illustration began to achieve
greater technical precision
and a brilliant and dreamlike hyper
aestheticism that showed off
with great artistry a more sophisticated
knowledge
and heightened perception of the
boundaries and surfaces of the body the
competition among anatomists for the
most elaborate
printed anatomical atlases
means that they're searching for the
best printers
the best engravers the best artists that
they can get
at the same time there's a competition
among printers for patronage and the
anatomical illustration
for them becomes an exemplary work it
helps foster the development of
improved technology so there's a
synergistic effect
[Music]
by 1800 anatomy had been defined as a
science
the investigation of the real rather
than an art
anatomy could no longer tolerate humor
fancy and ornament
yet fantastic images of the anatomical
body continued to proliferate
cast out of medical illustration
imaginative anatomy found
new homes in academic art where anatomy
was an important part of the curriculum
in popular health where the need to
appeal to the public
and a free hand inspired the creation of
vivid
playful and eccentric images and in
political cartoons
film and fiction wherever anatomical
images could be made to serve
in our society anatomy is seen as an
authoritative source for views of the
body
renderings of the body we have
faith in anatomical imaging that that
expresses
the reality of who we are and that's
a resource for artists who also want to
in a different way convey
the reality of the human body and the
reality of human existence
photography radiography digital imaging
and computer modelling
have multiplied the possibilities for
manipulation and play
artists and scientists are again
exploring
and re-imagining the body and
investigating the boundaries between
their respective disciplines we continue
to dream the anatomical body